one of the things that you did help me
adjust quite a bit was my my sleep and
I've I had built up this weird pattern
that was starting I thought to work for
me I would sleep three hours a night two
nights in a row then I would sleep nine
hours on the third night I don't know
why that worked for me at the time but
eventually it stopped working and I
realized that there was just a lot of
small adjustments that I needed to make
with screens and getting sunlight in the
morning can we talk about some of those
basic things that will help help out
with sleep quite a bit yeah
and why why is sleep so important and
why did we neglect it so much yeah I
mean I I can talk about some of the
practical concerns because I'm
definitely living it but Tommy's the
neuroscientist but actually should talk
about why sleep so important and well
there's both sides of that are very
important but in terms of the
practicality and then the science but
the so essentially
sleep is the only time that you have for
a lot of the tissues in the body to
repair and that goes from the brain all
the way out to the skin so there's even
some really interesting data on how
light at the wrong time on on the skin
at night when the skin is supposed to be
preparing itself that sort of
predisposes you to things like skin
cancers so even like sleep and darkness
at the right time a lot you know that's
when the body repairs itself essentially
that's when the brain flushes out all
the stuff that's been accumulating
during the day as you've been thinking
and and doing whatever it is that you do
during the day and in terms of the the
light exposure there's two important
parts to it so there's sunlight during
the day which helps time everything that
happens in the body happens on us what
we call a circadian rhythm so the jury
circa dere means roughly a day so
happens at a specific time during the
day and there are hundreds of genes and
proteins and things that your body makes
in different amounts depending on the
time of day and the way that your body
knows what time of day it is is it
should be sunlight bright light during
the day and you know right now we're
inside this is this would be nowhere
near enough light to set a circadian
rhythm even though it's it feels brights
compared to what you get from sunlight
it's really it's really nothing it's a
fraction and then at night you need
darkness because that tells your body
that it's nighttime but you produce of a
hormone called melatonin which some
people may have taken to try and help
them sleep because they spend their
evenings staring at a screen which
suppresses their body making melatonin
so blue and green lights particularly in
the bright LEDs that we get on screens
phones and computer screens and real and
televisions everything that you know is
really good at suppressing our melatonin
production and melatonin so it times the
clock it sets our metabolism but it also
has some you know antioxidant effects
anti-cancer effects they're using it in
for studies to try and repair injured
brains as part of cancer therapy so
melatonin has all these amazing effects
yet we're suppressing it by watching all
these screens at night and you know so
the two ways to prevent that is to make
sure we get Sun during the day which
again sort of helps prime us to make
melatonin a night and then also just
avoid those bright bright lights at
night yeah yeah I've added a few things
and you and I talked about this a little
bit like a sleep mask and and some
earplugs and and just some some really
basic things but it had more to do with
I think the the practice of getting
sunlight as soon as it's available I
tend to still wake up I'm just an early
bird so like I still wake up before the
Sun is up and so I got this thing called
a human charger and I don't know what
the science is behind it you've sent me
a few a few studies on it but what are
your thoughts on on sort of art the
artificial light from that so I think
that that can help its if nothing else
it certainly gives me the placebo we you
know we're big fans of the placebo if
you can get a placebo from something
that has literally zero downsides you
know that's great if it makes you feel
better than that and it's not displacing
something better but it's really good
for jet lag in particular so if you're
trying to time your circadian rhythm to
something that you're about to go to or
somewhere where you've just arrived you
know part of jetlag is the fact that
your body has no idea what time of day
it is right and so then the light and
the day and darkness and night is
big part of that so the human charge has
some great evidence for that but then
for the same reason if you're not going
to be exposed to bright light then
making sure that your body is getting
some of those cues at the right time
even if it's not from sunlight
I think can't can't have a big benefit
so it makes sense yeah and I was living
in Montana at the time too so like all
winter it's dark and cloudy and the Sun
of them come up until I swear as well as
a shot like 10 a.m. or something crazy
it is still bright out there right
compared to what the the light level of
light that you experience indoors get
light meter right sunrise wasn't until
like 10:00 a.m. and I went oh yeah I
would get up at like like 4 or 5 oh wow
okay
and so even between you know I'd have
five hours between sunrise even though
it was cloudy yes so you would still
have brightness but it was diffused
through many many levels
yeah yeah I mean it's it's Canada
basically
you